So we have to have a conversation today.
That might be difficult for some in our audience,
but it must be done because the stakes are
really high at this point.
Think back to 2016 before the November of
2016 election.
You had people on the left who were saying
things like, you know, if it's Trump versus
Hillary, I'd rather it be Trump, really.
I'd rather it be Bernie or Jill Stein or some
other so-called real leftist.
But if it's Trump versus Hillary, Hillary
will just reinforce the status quo. Trump
will be so different, maybe wacky, that he
will totally shake up the system and set the
stage for a real progressive in 2020.
We have almost four years now of a Trump presidency
and it hasn't happened.
And it's another data point that these ideas
of acceleration ism haven't worked.
Now, I know you might be thinking, David,
you're wrong.
It's you know, we need eight years of Trump
instead of four for this to work or.
David, you're wrong.
Trump has shaken things up such that we now
will become super progressive or something.
The answer to those rebuttals is no.
And I'll go through them one by one in a moment.
But first, we need to sort of understand what
we're talking about when we talk about acceleration
ism.
There's narrow acceleration ism and then there's
like the broader colloquial use of the term
acceleration ism.
So narrow acceleration ism.
If you if you look at the origins or origins
of these ideas generally refers to capitalism
and socialism.
And the idea is in order to get rid of capitalism,
you accelerate it.
Right.
You go to like uber super ultimate, extreme
free market capitalism that will more quickly
break and then it will come radical change,
socialism, some other completely different
system.
So in other words, feed capitalism so that
it collapses.
Now, if we say acceleration ism more broadly,
it's not so much about capitalism versus socialism
necessarily.
It's the idea of accelerate the destruction
of the current system by putting in place
crazier and crazier leaders so that we speed
up the system, failing and then being able
to replace it with something better.
Some other people characterize it as burn
it down to rebuild it properly.
So when some on the left said back in 2016,
I'm a Bernie person, so I'm like 98 percent
on board with Bernie's ideas.
You know, maybe I'm 60 percent on board with
Hillary and I'm 10 percent on board with Trump.
But I still want Trump because Trump will
violate norms and violate conventions and
do things that will accelerate the total downfall
of the system.
And then we will usher in a real era of true
progressivism in 2020.
So, listen, we've got four years of Trump,
three and a half years.
So far, it has done very little for the progressive
movement in any real way.
We got Trump, the most lethal, incompetent
president we've had in the modern political
era.
He's failed on everything, right.
The bogus tax reform plan, the trade war disaster
with China.
He failed on Corona virus.
He's failed on, you know, of immigration.
He tried but failed to get rid of the Affordable
Care Act.
But certainly we've not made progress when
it comes to health care.
He has failed, failed, failed while making
the United States a laughingstock.
And what it led to is a center left Democratic
nominee of Joe Biden, who may win or may not
win.
So despite those who in 2016 said Trump will
accelerate, you know, some kind of progressive
revolution and it's better that he become
president than Hillary because she will essentially
maintain the status quo.
It didn't happen.
So what do we have to do to hold those folks
accountable?
People saying if it can't be a progressive
that meets my standards, then I'd rather it
be Trump because his failures will usher in
progressivism.
Well, they haven't.
They've ushered in being out of the Paris
climate accords and falling further and further
behind on taking care of the environment and
the planet.
They've ushered in a corona virus response
that has completely failed and led to unnecessary
death.
They've ushered in tax cuts that have completely
failed to actually improve circumstances.
And now we just find ourselves with more damage
to undo.
If Joe Biden does win in November and takes
over in January, he simply has more damage
to undo than what we would have had Donald
Trump lost in November of 2016.
So let's now deal with some of the inevitable
talking points.
Here's one.
You know what, David?
Four years of Trump would have ushered in
progressive change if the DNC hadn't stolen
the 20 20 Democratic nomination from Bernie
and given it to Joe Biden.
Come on, guy.
Come on, guys.
Bernie lost by a lot before he dropped out.
Bernie was already losing the Democratic primary
by a couple million votes.
Bernie lost Super Tuesday and then he lost
Super Tuesday number two, and then he lost
Super Tuesday number three.
At that point, we already were starting to
deal with coronavirus stay at home.
So, yes, centrist candidates like P and Amy
got out of Biden's way.
But this doesn't change that.
Bernie never had more than mid to high 30s
support period, no matter how many other candidates
there were.
The acceleration, honest arguments about that
inevitability were simply wrong.
And to be perfectly frank, how weak is your
argument that if four years of Trump was going
to bring in progressive change, inevitably
it simply failed because Pete and Amy got
out.
And that's why Bernie lost.
I think that it's a very weak argument.
If it could so easily be interfered with by
Pete and Amy ending their campaigns to help
Joe Biden.
Now, there's going to be another argument,
which is Trump's presidency will be acceleration
EST, but we need eight years of Trump instead
of four.
Right.
In other words, we were right in 2016 that
Trump, instead of Hillary, would usher in
progressive change through a burn it down
and in order to rebuild that sort of perspective.
But four years isn't enough.
We need a full eight years of Donald Trump
to fall.
It's a completely post hoc rationalization.
None of these folks were saying back in 2016,
Trump will reinvigorate the progressive movement,
but it will take eight years instead of four.
They are having to say that now because they
were just wrong in 2016.
So we need another framework.
Hillary Clinton was no progressive.
But if Hillary Clinton were president or corona
virus, death toll would be lower.
It wouldn't be zero.
But we have studies from Columbia University
and others.
If we had a coordinated stay at home one week
earlier, we could have avoided thirty thousand
of the hundred thousand deaths.
If it had been two weeks earlier, we might
have avoided fifty to sixty five thousand
of the hundred thousand deaths that would've
been different.
If Hillary were president, Hillary were president,
we would still be in the Paris climate agreement
and we would not have softened fuel emission
standards.
We would not have a ridiculous trade war going
on with China.
So let's really understand that when people
say now, if it's not Bernie, I'd rather another
four years of Trump.
Why four years of Trump messed up so many
of our systems.
But those systems aren't really any closer
to going away.
They're just messed up.
Four years of Trump damaged our planet more
than it had to.
And we can't get those four years back.
Four years of Trump didn't get us a progressive
nominee.
History tells us that progress comes in modern
political systems like the one we have in
the United States.
Progress comes in steps.
Now, I've given these examples before, but
they're important to repeat.
You've got the progressive era of the eighteen
nineties to the 1920s.
You've got the New Deal era.
Officially, it's 1933 to 1939.
Some people consider it to be a little bit
bigger than that.
You've got the civil rights era from the end
of the 1950s until, you know, into the 60s.
It's easy to look back now and say, wow, look
at that insane list of accomplishments.
Now, with the benefit of hindsight, we see
it.
But if you were in the middle of the progressive
era of the late 80s, 90s and into early 1920s.
Thirty years is a long time.
If you're in the middle of it, it probably
doesn't feel like such significant change.
But when you look back and you see, wow, the
community activism slowly eking out a better
Supreme Court, a lot of the Progressive Era
reforms were upheld because we had the right
Supreme Court right.
Supreme Court Justice Charles Evan Hughes,
Justice Oliver Wendell Holmes, Herbert Hoover
nominating Charles, Evan Hughes, Teddy Roosevelt
nominating Oliver Wendell Holmes.
It didn't seem like big progressive change
at the time, but some of the biggest advancements
now that we now take for granted during that
era came from exactly this type of incrementalism.
It's boring.
I know it, but it's what worked.
When you look at would Trump get to replace
Ruth Bader Ginsburg or would Biden get to
replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg if she retires?
That may not seem like that big of a deal
to some people.
But history tells us that it is.
Look then at the New Deal era of the 30s under
Franklin Delano Roosevelt.
This came out of the Great Depression.
It included changes that now are considered
to be just fundamental parts of the fabric
of the country.
But they weren't burnt down revolution things.
That was regulate the banking industry programs
to support farmers, the unemployed, young
people, elderly folks creating Social Security,
which is huge.
Of course, you didn't get that by burning
down the system.
You didn't get it by saying, hey, you know
what?
Instead of FDR, because it can't be a super
progressive, let's elect some right wing nut.
No, it didn't happen that way.
History tells us.
Lastly, the civil rights era, right, of the
50s into the 60s, filled with protests and
sit ins and rallies and a ton of the day to
day elements that we often see today and and
say today really would need to be scaled up.
But a lot of the progress was.
1954, Brown vs. the Board of Education.
That was an early movement, an early moment
in the civil rights era.
And it was a decision made by the Supreme
Court reinforcing the importance of who gets
to pick the justices.
Is it Trump or is it Biden?
1956 and double ACP works within the judiciary
to win desegregation of the bus system.
Fifty seven.
Martin Luther King creates the SDLC to support
local protest movements.
You've got the new North Carolina drugstore
sitting in 1960, which sparks more sit ins.
These were not burn it down acceleration ist
events.
These were really important areas of progress
that took a while that were incremental.
And we've wasted four years with Donald Trump.
We've wasted four years where some progress
could have been made.
And you now would have to redirect the ship,
so to speak, less so than it will have to
be redirected when Donald Trump eventually
leaves.
We have a choice.
There is no reason to make the same mistake
again in November.
People's lives are riding on it.
And we need to understand the same argument
that's being made now about, listen, if it's
Biden, give Trump another four years.
People made that argument in 2015, 2016.
It failed.
Look at what happened.
There is no empirical case for saying, well,
another four years will finally fix it.
It's not how the system is designed.
It's not what's going to happen.
If you disagree, let me know.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman and I welcome
your comments.
Also, remember to sign up for the David Pakman
show audio podcast.
Lot of you that watch our clips on YouTube
may not know.
We've got an audio podcast free every day.
Get it on iTunes, Stitcher, Google Play podcasts,
our Web site.
It's everywhere.
And it is one of the more popular ways to
consume the show every day.
Quick break.
Right back after this.